hello dude whatever man back from
Nashville the old nasty home of music I
like LA but but a little bit different a
little more hometown what do you think
the bars I felt were the same flavor as
Los Angeles Wow little better though
little black music career which I
appreciate as do a lot of white girls on
booze cruises everywhere yes there are
bats rat capital of the world yes there
are on my nerves that's right I should
get you it's the craziest it's the
craziest Bachelorette magnet it kind of
it's nuts I don't like them at my show
at all oh hell no Marc Maron kicked him
out
there's the bachelor that probably
kicked him out really what the man was
tell me at Zanies someone called and was
like hey we have not my show like month
prior goes hey you know we have a party
of 20 bachelorettes and he goes this
ain't it and they do studios she owes
we're gonna buy over like 30 tickets I
don't care this isn't the spot for you
yeah Tony this is comedy show we don't
need your money like nah we don't mean
it for the comic won't be good for you
don't need a bunch of girls who are
drunk talking and correct mooing yes you
don't man be like nope out I don't blame
ya what what um if you could play an
instrument if you could be in a band
David guitar sabado baby it's piano
piano piano be cool I feel like if I
could just get on that guitar and do
something like Dave Matthews yeah
satellite in my not a bad deal out of
that whose are you Dave Matthews fan how
can you not be a little bit guys are you
gonna hate on us no come on he's got a
turtle right yeah do that again that was
good not good you're not that good
usually at in person I know that it was
not bad do I love David again I want to
hear it again you've been listening man
I got to hear it let me hear it jack
my he's so good just a second with a
Wi-Fi oh it's down yeah you fix you have
you could do a cover of Dave Matthews
chin [ __ ] you I could part do pretty
much I'd say cry anything and do it oh
yeah he's very good yeah you know you
know I got on this kick with him because
he was on Howard Stern that's like I
still love Dave Matthews so I've been
going down this whole catalog I
celebrate all his catalog here's the
thing if you don't like Dave Matthews
just I understand but please look at put
yourself in a position where you've been
hearing a lot of music and then you he
comes along he's unique he's got a very
unique voice and sound so just the pum
pum pum pum pum pum yes teacher when he
was growing up used to make him warm up
with a with this you know I was going
his teachers to make him warm up so he
went into it the studio and told his he
was doing his bands like oh we could do
something with that and then he's
surrounded by like musical geniuses so
they're like oh let's try this and then
he starts writing lyrics
what a [ __ ] Jam he's not American you
know that he's not South South African
he is yep SATs at yeah in high school as
dads I mean we I mean that's pretty good
you take Suggs like some Dave Matthews
he's not gay gay man is he really he's
marrying know what that's fine but
lowers followers called chin uh Dave
have slaves Dave slit I'm at a Flav now
take it easy dude fact that now listen
I'm a day fly if you know what that
entails bro I'm a Dave flip but no day a
day friend where you going cuz I want a
slave brave dad Brendan Brendan Jaime's
brave brave Brennan listen me hey buddy
is slave cuz he's gonna make it do some
stuffy gay he's gay
dude if he plays that Santa pants off
and you're gonna have to end up whatever
dude I'm a Dave slave he had a
girlfriend dude he's not gay he's I'm
talking and the Sun god damn he's been
married like seven bothers me about that
[ __ ] rumor dick anyway this is what
this is where I got that from ready cuz
in the back of my mind I remember some
of the saying oh I have a friend hit on
and now my guys gay
all right this Dave Matthews getting up
that's a rumor with everybody though
yeah
like me especially these days bring up
David Fassbender's dick please I'm sorry
to do this but he's got apparently in
shame I got to see this everybody keeps
talking to real yeah it's his real dick
apparently he's got a craving Mike
Michael Fassbender hey FASS Michael
Fassbender yeah yeah you're talking
about a magneto yeah he's got a crazy
magneto has a [ __ ] dude I mean
apparently though it's like what not big
in the news from Mad Men you've seen a
guy from Mad Men when he's walked across
street in these jeans
ah no that's distracting dude no but
this is this he's got a crazy piece on
him oh no you can tell that baby sure
there's a picture Bachelor yeah okay oh
the movie shame yeah no you should see
is dick what it's 100% his gay do you
say type in shame shame dick pic hey did
you see or not you wouldn't see this
when I so I fly out of Burbank these
days ways in LAX there's some get worker
there dude this dude had an ass I'm not
getting at least bit but I looked at
dirt gets on away I don't think eyes
asked is so distracting what indictor
drangus oh my god he has some Kate
this dude was wearing these black khakis
and I don't know if he had injections or
what I mean a Nicki Minaj ass so he was
a small black man well he's a black man
like the fattest eyes you've ever seen
but nobody has a better outlet after
that nobody has a better ass in then you
know who our boy from the UFC Oh Cody no
Cody is a great ass I don't know I never
saw Cody Cody is some cheeks I know I'm
talking about I'm talking about Hector
Lombard remember this couple one to
candy and I stopped we've stopped in the
security line Brennan and I he was
wearing a pair of white sweats and Bren
and I were like well that's crazy I
think that if this in shame I doubt it's
his real Digby no they say it is his
real dick and then there was a big talk
about all their ghosts here's Michael
Fassbender shock and shame no it says
here's Michael Fassbender shock and
shame one more down one more down oh
there you go yeah okay but hit but the
only way we got here is because you said
Dave Matthews is a gay man yeah
I mean because almost Dave slave yeah
you didn't see Dave slave right don't
like that torture that's a creepy when
you're well this website's not gay at
all huh now how does your how was your
wait come on up down eight pounds bro is
that true eight pounds what's up to 65
this morning okay sixty five point four
is it you were gonna get down to two 35
35
I lost eight pounds eleven days yeah but
you want to keep it on all right you're
big-boned brother you know I'm saying
I'm to do it though you know I feel like
you got even taller good but I'm wearing
flips even flips your shooting right now
I'm shooting right now my middle of
shooting I came to do the podcast and I
have to run back and finish up the scene
this is this school or is this school
this is Goldberg good to see everybody -
well the best part about it of being on
a set is not the acting or use the crew
and everybody that you get to know
everybody holy - Hollywood who works in
TV is a [ __ ] professional no one felt
a CSIS hold my bare butt yeah but nobody
[ __ ] up like nobody's late nobody tell
about the crew oh my god well you're not
gonna make it in this business fits to
cutthroat yes yeah so many people they
got tattoos on their calves they got
their hair oh yeah doesn't matter
they're them they're phenomenal well you
guys you know right now I am we are
shooting in Culver City us so many
studios yeah it's two minutes two
minutes yeah well great
yeah it's pretty great I like it so
don't ask you about Dave Matthews
definite gay yeah what were we talking
about you were saying oh yeah
Nashville live music oh that's just
great and what was Jay Shaab with you
Jay Saab was with me Derek and asam were
with me what did you guys do during the
day strolled around you know stroll
around just stroke stroll dude we had to
be into steak house okay
we had some good food found some of the
best barbecue where Derek and a sunny
that Hattie B's which like the famous
disaster with chicken yeah I can't eat
that cuz my diet get me to 35 you still
on keto oh yeah so when you let a date
12 a strong you go and do barbecue what
is it you're eating just ribs with no
sauce
plain and just ribs and no sauce sauce
Wow
no cornbread oh god no no collard greens
you can eat some collard greens you
could yeah you can't you're not doing in
greens either I do some greens the pants
I didn't call greens out there
you just ate ribs i shaped ribs and then
[ __ ] look and then dry brisket known as
[ __ ] lot let's think about keto never
that hungry
I mean eaten today yet really nope in a
bunch of fat last night a bunch of fat
but what do you have rib eye salad notes
I'm past the point now now I'm good I
don't feel like cheating anymore really
nope I don't feel like peels or anything
yeah we'll see how long it lasts dude
but I've been going strong October did
you know I can make heavyweight now I'm
265 if yet if they call me up I can make
it right now last week I'm gonna make it
it's it's astonishing you're that big
it's something it's not cool
yeah even to six fights too big just a
giant what's funny is I talk about
people at my show like do huge weight
man like relax relax 265 pounds yeah
love small oh you put weight on you know
in a uniform way I feel like I don't
think you put them on it goes everywhere
it goes everywhere little bit in the
face yeah I didn't go like that
I did a girl like that she put on weight
but I I liked it cuz she put it on
everywhere they go into booty yeah but
but kind of like it was just like
uniform yeah all right we were talking
good about yet
Dorfman the owner of Dorfman we went out
to lunch were a great guy here's the
he's been comedy for ever
there's some great stories man yes
brother he knows everybody what
everybody likes Bryan so guys like that
Brian his brother people like those guys
you know certain there are certain club
owners there's ones you like you can
hang out with yes there's ones where
they hang out the green room we're like
dear God get out of here ma'am I know
I'm friends with door friends not that
he's great whereas the best stories
about comedy like amazing stories been
around you guys on tour with Charlie
Murphy was for I mean you're talking
about you named a comic Dave Attell he
knows all the B's are the guys that
watched Rogan and Chris Hart and a none
Chappelle's a Chris Hart and I mean
Chris Hart Jesus and Chris Hart and
let's and all these guys in bill burr
all of them they walked they they were
with them when they were making two
grand a weekend and you know me like I
love talking comedy like when you're at
a comic didn't really want to talk about
with Dorfman a historian comic so yeah
he goes who's your favorite comedian I
went I guess who thinks you who's your
top three best I'll fee it's all you
know here whatever you like best
there's no number one comic and I said I
think bill burr is the best you know
comic alive right now and when I agree
and then but he gives out
he has specific reasons he saw bill burr
20 years ago like he he can go through
the time Oberth it but he also has his
ear to the ground cause he he was I go
well in New York yacht Andrew Schultz
who's killing it
yeah mark Normand ago and then I'll talk
about the first time they came through
he's just a month
oh yeah and people get better if you're
writing and you're thinking we we were
at lunch and he brought he has two sons
one who just graduated from call or high
school and he's in between he's playing
he's trying to go get a scholarship to
college for high hockey so they're big
hockey plates from Chicago but then they
got to sell a friend named cookie last
name cooked they called cookie and he
plays video games for ten hours a day
and he's like shop telling her I needs
to get out of the [ __ ] bedroom and
just start living life and then you know
the kids go well that one dude did win
seven million the show three male why
whatever's three 700 and fine that's
that's fine that's fine he did that you
know he tricks that guy gets zero Matt
don't you want to meet girls have
[ __ ] communication skills you're not
like that guy who makes three million
instead million he might get some chick
but he's just playing video games
talking [ __ ] to his friends all the time
right now you'd only get some Sun bro
it's weird how video games are a job for
a lot of people though yeah there's
money there now it's so big and everyone
plays that they just bound to happen or
gamer
yeah I'm commenting on game yeah it's so
strange to me it's a whole economy yeah
but I I get it I mean I listen it's it's
a booming and there's pro teams and they
make serious money but listen if you
were just
if your defense of playing video games
15 hours a day and not talking to people
and looking like a vampire if you're
like well you can make millions of
dollars I get that from unease your only
motivation okay that that's that's an
argument doesn't mean you're be happy
doesn't mean you're gonna live a
fulfilling life I don't know it's almost
like your life is a simulation and
you're not you're living in the fake you
just not do I don't know I I don't know
I can't I'm older it's creative its
competitive its it's you you are focused
on one thing and maybe that's what you
love to do it's hard to it's hard to say
it I I do think it puts people in a
state of flow like they get into a
complete state of concentration and like
it's a little bit like the way chess
players can play all day you know chess
player those chess matches last forever
and they're just it's all strategy and
they're all focused on ass let's just
plays get yeah but it's never about ask
for them it's no I did I'm just saying
you gotta live a little your
communication skills with opposite sex
aren't gonna be great men yeah but then
there are Gator girls
there are gamer gals that they date too
you guys can go out a day and play video
game so I went to my kids were at coding
camp your kids are at coding camp for
four days you know just like where you
learn how to code and the kids that were
teenagers that were coders I this is my
theory because they are in front of a
computer all day and they don't do any
physical you're by body so when you're
at so when you do exercise like when you
lift weights I'll tell older people to
lift weights because calcium rushes to
the bones it's a really good way to
create bone density and everything
clicker bones everything you don't do
that and you've been on the desk from up
from a little kill your shoulders go
check please so crazy there's something
fooled in yeah it's a posture of a
[ __ ] centipede yep super skinny and
super frail-looking
the kids much programming camp though
huh just for four days that's cool my
son said you know Jays a computer
programmer yes my son's in baseball camp
right now how'd you see oh don't try
making that up
no he is buddy what the program camp
before yeah that's interesting where was
that at uh it's at the it's at his
school they they have code you later
cause you don't code for video
games yeah oh no it's big it's big yeah
that's the reason J majored in computer
programming cuz my dad's like if you
want a job right when he get off College
majoring computer programming yeah
that's what J did yeah get it he had
like seven job offers before you even
graduate Wow
but now the thing is that for the things
you learned for the first two years are
already irrelevant like that's how fast
[ __ ] is moving like that's irrelevant we
don't do that anymore
Hansie what but you gotta study it it's
so crazy yeah you always you gotta keep
moving that Alvin Toffler whatever he
said if you want to compete in the 21st
century you have to learn how to learn
unlearn and relearn yeah you can't be
stuck in your ways you got it I was
talking to Dorfman and Lucy the general
manager over at Nashville Zanies we're
talking about comics and out certain
comics at this level but they have no
social presence or they don't care no
podcast and refuse to do social media or
any media luck and there is like I mean
I get I there's a complicated ex tweek
who absolute monster might self 14th
pick damn they just and he doesn't care
as a matter well good luck with that
baby you know Netflix I got a little
insight into how Netflix works you want
to talk about a monster
they're so global you're talking about a
thirteen billion dollar budget thirteen
billion dollar just for just for like
their sci-fi channel okay oh but I told
you I'd like to Whitney about her
special yeah and you know what she had a
she had a name originally for the
special but she met with the team at
Netflix I went there you don't
understand so in in our world Whitney or
name any comic you want Hannibal Buress
anybody they're big in our world in the
grand scheme of things they're not that
big so if you want to reach millions
upon millions people just the title of
loan has to be catchy American boner
that wasn't rushed on that certain
titles the shirt title was pretty safe
through it no no so what's the title can
I touch it even if you're if you're not
familiar with Whitney you see can I
touch it out stand up that's [ __ ]
hilarious I'll make my way special
American boner would be huge yeah that's
the reason you do that stuff
so there's they're saying like even
I forget the comic but he had a thing
where it was just him like this and that
the title was real small but he was big
not too many people clicked on it now
they switch it where the titles huge and
is a mic like 60% more people click that
they don't know who he is but they are
just looking for comedy yeah they have
crates who have the average cost 9
million dollars for like just say let's
there sci-fi channel 9 million in
episode it used to be a million dollars
in episode was like crazy so stranger
things it's something like 10 million
dollars in episode yeah it's like a mini
movie right which is so [ __ ] not as
pretty much money I got stranger things
oh it's it's it's crazy but the they
have an ability to where they can um
they can see so they would they have to
find a location where they want to shoot
it they put it into an algorithm and
it's like this is how much it costs you
ting Bulgaria's sounds custom shooting
romeo they have it and then they have a
actress they're like they can't you're
you're a number now you're an actor this
is these are the actors that can get a
certain number of views it's all
becoming so you know even in comedy
though they can go okay well if they if
you say hey I've this hour what do you
think of it think all right well we know
no matter who it is with it's Chris Rock
Bill burr or the small guy on the totem
pole people watched about 23 minutes in
so it has to be [ __ ] five so you're
closer that you're saving at the very
end yeah you should put in the front
yeah most people aren't gonna make it
that far if they do they watch it in
blocks yeah the chopping it up so it's
crazy to me so and by the way in a lot
of ways Hollywood has kind of lost its
relevance financially and they don't
even know it yet I mean the world the
global market is so much bigger now it's
so big that Hollywood is like the day of
the movie star dramas where you put like
Giuliani SHhhh
it really doesn't exist anymore well
everyone has their own like fanbase
everything's very neat you're not even
making dramas anymore it's like dramas
are not really what they used to be you
just don't do it oh this guy Nate
bargatze he's gonna do our special he's
great
I'm he sent ones like yeah he's great
he's a big natural comedian monster
great super monster brave best special
on Netflix oh my gosh yeah I told him to
come on monster he'll be on but
Fury's going with oh I crossed inna you
know Tom's life Christina yeah P she
we're basically neighbors but I saw out
Whole Foods and I demon rec and I saw
she had some cool tie-dyed pants on some
like the Lea would wear that caught my
attention but her kid man they have a
one and a half year old it looks
identical to Tom he's a girl but this
this guy um said this thing this kid is
so [ __ ] cute that's what I didn't I
didn't realize even for a second I was
waiting to get some meat at the the
counter and I see this kid combining
both little head out from his mom I was
like good god that's a Gerber baby oh my
kids cute as [ __ ] they Christina goes
Shaun like oh [ __ ]
like he looks like uncle to Tom she was
it's a shame in it she's so funny she's
great but there dude
they don't post picture their kid I
don't think but god damn this kid is
cute man yeah a little Gerber baby a
little Gerber baby god it was cute I
reminded me of something and I camera
what the hell it was
yeah they don't post pictures of their
kid oh yeah some kids up top I'm not
sure where they are
ah that's Ally wonks here that's them in
the pool with those crazy hats on
fantastic yeah super cute though yeah
the kid I mean I didn't realize
Christine the kids so goddamn cute
blinding cute some people one thing
about how I'm gonna get my American
boner on Netflix my next special
American voter absolutely crush cuz we
we always overt like all my fan fan base
well your people gonna watch you gotta
hit the math if the masses are funny
titles that's [ __ ] it means all the
fans all of us here all the fans are
saying like please do that title too
much official policy comment about
American boy it was the best idea yeah
you know you know I've been doing on the
road now be as I create exclusive merge
just for that city so like Nast rely did
the cover of my boy Zack did the we did
the cover up I get Johnny no no Jack
Daniel's bottle huh
but put I love it I saw that so we did
shirts and have
so that right away I I just I were doing
something that yeah I will be do
specific city merch only now so like for
Portland we're doing voodoo donuts like
the logo booty to suit just certain city
I said just all general that's what
we've been doing something great I need
a good yeah I got you when you get where
you get you off-the-road for a while so
we can figure it out okay perfect that's
beautiful yeah and it just sells cuz I
thought if ik to that yep I like that I
like the business your business is cool
huh well what's [ __ ] crazy about this
businesses I love doing my TV show it's
amazing but but it is a it used to be
when you had an ABC TV show that was it
you were done it's all good but stand up
and podcasting is the new blood so to
take a break from mattis is is actually
well plus you own all this big yeah it's
actually tough you know it's tough
financially it means there's no there's
things you know ya know it's interesting
though yeah yeah it is I met I met
Whitney for coffee later and we're
talking about just comedy and everything
like that and because I've only too much
into it cuz it [ __ ] me but we're
talking about like agents and managers
stuff like that and I was trying to
figure something out I'll talk to you
later about us finding out that she goes
well what do you want
Thanks I can't remember I don't think it
was a very important question the most
important question but no there are a
few I went I don't know she knows and
then you expected them to know know what
well I want this is this you you know
you tell me what you're doing but what
do you want what do you want and let me
tell you something that forces you to
confront some [ __ ] nobody very few
people if you're young and listening
than this ask yourself that question
what do you want really be honest
because when you ask yourself what you
really want I believe it's probably the
closest thing to getting to know who you
really are
yeah like what do you when you look at
what somebody honestly Revere's what
they honestly want it's it's probably
the best indication of who they are and
the reason I say that is because a lot
of times people don't want success so
they they basically do all these really
heavy lies the crown [ __ ] yet they'll do
all these
sure their own failure I see it over and
over again ask yourself why are you
doing this why well this all came from
and talk to you off here about this all
came from because Justin see a real I go
with this movie role in this TV I went
alright I don't think I I don't think I
wanna do that that's not the stuff what
I'm doing is so goddamn tough over here
I don't have time to get stretched over
there you want to be a great comic yeah
that's all I mean and it's okay that's
it but that's what I told them I went so
anything that distract you but this
Kabul that channels realize away no
that's why I told I said so you want me
to go over here to do that you want me
to drive down take this out it's just
not it's not in you I know I don't want
that right now if CEO Chris D'Elia Brian
will sasso we're doing a buddy comedy
sure I'll get to hang out well then I'm
it but if you expect me to it's just not
play a bad guy in this what it's not you
know it's a but and like I said all the
answers lie in comedy stand-up comedy by
the way get really good stand-up and and
which I truly believe you can do and and
then from there all the movie stuff will
open up anyway maybe but who cares right
the other thing is yeah you listen take
it from the guy who spent a lot of time
on a set yeah you and you and I are
similar this way you you don't want to
spend a lot of time I said people could
see what it is it's standing around and
waiting god I just got just my you know
a little bit of taste when I'd shot the
the tax collector I'm like oh another
watch Shia LaBeouf and these real actors
chill too and then do the scene like
yeah dude this what do you want when you
really great question event that [ __ ]
question and I had to do that for a long
time and I was like I remember hat doing
that I had a tug come to Jesus moment
with myself a number of times that way
because I was like I'm doing this all
this stuff over here and I don't it's
probably because I don't want what I
think I want I came to this town to be
an actor yep to be in films yep and
you've done and I really studied at and
I really worked hard at it and I got
good but I didn't want it as much as I
wanted to be well you don't know
compared to stand up yeah compared to
the feeling I get when I'm on so what's
interesting is
like Dorfman was that weird time buy in
your cells Brian don't like the you know
his two hit shows by the ABC and doing
the damn thing and then he goes oh he
must be thrilled me cuz he won't be an
actor I'm like I think he's grateful but
I you know or some RIA but I but nothing
takes the place of stand-up comedy
unless someone's like hey you wanna be
Batman
you know but then I don't know I don't
know dude I don't know that is that's a
lot of makeup and a lot of waiting
around a lot of CGI yeah I don't know
dude I got friends who are movie stars
and yeah yeah yeah beasts mm-hmm our boy
Frank Grillo I don't know if you get
movie star now I see I've seen the
billboards on but that bad [ __ ] movie
on Netflix speaking of Netflix I think
it's the number like it's some crate 45
million people have seen that movie
point-blank so far well you know you
know yeah there's - that's wheelman and
Point Blank now he's crushing he just
he's about to some shits going on well
he's all right yeah I mean what's like
Adam Sandler's movies the most watched
thing on Netflix ever you know that know
his new is bring that up chin Adam sell
yeah something like something to him and
Jeff Ranson it's like the most watch in
a day ever
I didn't know that yeah their murder
mystery proves just how attractive em
Stiller is there you go 73 million
households whoa damn Wow
as an amazing will a record-breaking 73
million households watch the movie in
the first month of its release that's
insanity that's insanity my favorite
people hate on that I'm selling okay
okay yeah yeah yeah
oh you think Netflix is giving him a
[ __ ] 8 movie deal because he sucks I
haven't thought of a matrix yeah yeah
yeah you don't think they're just
metrics for them 30,000 30 million
accounts for 3 days 30 million dude the
biggest opening weekend ever for Netflix
film well so so so Point Blank 45
million crazy crazy Wow [ __ ] yeah Adam
Adam cellars kind of hot if you think
about it well you know that's yeah I
will always be sexy to me yes they look
good too
killing it man well
god bless them in that crazy yeah how
many how many people's I make how many
people have Netflix worldwide everyone
how would you that does it say chin it's
almost like one player in town is it
like you're billion
well they do it's one player but it's
slow like because now Disney goes all
that oh that's the future cool a Netflix
will take all our comic-book stuff yeah
everybody's coming that friends too yeah
we're gonna take all that and then
Disney and goes now we're gonna launch
ours now effects and Amazon room is okay
this is the move now Apple so that it's
just that's what it was the first two
third dance I got so now the [ __ ]
truck loads are now it's just it's just
FX to start doing 30 minute specials
Hulu right Amazon you know and then
what's [ __ ] Disney gets involved
they're gonna start it's all coming man
everything's going digital yeah I guess
Netflix is the first people to really
understand the algorithm which puts put
the jump which puts 139 million
subscribers worldwide approaching 150
million 150 mm that's insane that's
[ __ ] insane so one point so broke it
out and added 1.5 mm scrub in the US
seven million you know 150 million but
then they this has been their first kind
of quarter where they're down though
because they increase their price so
people dropped it oh okay oh yeah
they'll be fine
but they're the other players are coming
yeah interesting right it really is I'm
separated Christian Brennan what are you
doing hey well you were staring at me
and I thought you were asking my new
hoard no I didn't know I don't know I
didn't tell you talk about this yeah I
just say you guys know for the past year
I've been separated but we've kept it
kind of under wraps not divorced or no I
mean I get along with mom yeah that mean
well yeah I love her she does great way
the best
but no when when everything is grading
he has a cold change it every day yes
guys live close so I just wanted to let
they get that out there about time it's
about time
III know cuz I've been keeping a lot
I've only been keeping it quiet because
I think we wanted to tell the kids
properly or sure you know what it's like
kids didn't even night kids were like
but wait I thought you were working I
was like nah you know you're always at
the house and then you know exactly and
wait I get along so well with mom here's
the thing not that big of a deal to look
man we we added Celeste your guns it's
way 12 years so if you're run dude
that's a success bad right I don't know
why I don't know why people look at
divorces a failure or like people are
afraid to a minute 12 years to the same
page friends and now and and great
friends still yeah still a lot of love
yeah which is huge but also you guys you
know you get two beautiful children yeah
it 12-year relationship you know a long
12 years it to be with the same person
they're men
that's insane yeah look at the odds man
that's a success she deserves a lot of
she does all the trophies Amanda I know
you listen the show I've been married to
Brian for how long seven years now
here's now seven seven year in a
marriage you were in a marriage you've
been writing for 12 yeah you deserve a
goddamn no she does no she does award no
no 100% she everyone was frustrated
married I'm married to a [ __ ] comic
okay end up calm so she used the travel
a different animal nama die needs
attention all I'm a disaster zester yeah
and she's just but she's such a she's
very very confident she's so um centered
she's like yeah she's a centered she
just knows exactly what the [ __ ] you
know this is gonna hurt just a tad what
just tell you what dude why are you at
my house a lot oh god this is awkward
I'm gonna come and give you a shovel you
think is weird your kids call me papa
y'all slap you up let me slap you up I'm
I slap you up can you imagine
I'm trying to be you know I'm trying to
be right now you might get slapped up I
don't my closet oh yeah a my Ma's Vidale
your ass okay man does it feel better
now to talk about it though yeah I mean
I just don't you know me yeah how long
you know me I don't like secrets no
you know everything about me you know me
I'm I'm always I think the best the
reason why podcasting works this much
for me is I'm as honest as it gets on
him yep you know I'm saying so for you I
always thought it it was best if you
could just come out yeah I think you're
stand-ups gonna be better I think you're
also your life is better yeah I just
don't like secrets and and I mean like
people always say like they say well I
think I feel like I know you you do know
me you do know me we talk about
everything on this podcast just about so
there it is boom dude single and ready
to mingle you can't date single ready to
mingle
now Amanda you need anything what don't
drink your straw inside of your mouth
like that your boys here I don't like
that and finally wrinkles is that all my
friends every time I FaceTime my friend
is a code word under all my friends are
like like taric's like let me talk to
you lady and I and I put the camera on
his shirts off he's like what
son of a [ __ ] in a man had a code word
is wrinkles out wrinkles out wrinkles
out it goes in wisdom
get the [ __ ] out although I'm shaved
look a lot younger huh guys
yeah guys gonna get mad my lids are you
so are you last thing about in Nashville
remember when we're in Nashville and our
girl you girl you do Goldberg with yeah
beautiful Haley Haley Haley I ranches
she's still out there she's back on the
Goldbergs oh she said she has a house
out there yeah I remember oh yeah
remember her singing oh my god Haley I
ran she just started singing out a piano
Brenda and I covered our mouths she
starts singing and Brennan are crying
and covered our mouths yes yeah like
like we went you know how you like oh ha
over just still going she that's a but
she does seasoned ladies and gentlemen
seventh [ __ ] C's that's pretty yeah
she's a chicken she sings a change she
just got another album don't say cut I
don't I said I don't know she is singing
but she can sing say yeah yeah yeah you
can hear there she's hitting that high
note she just seems so finishing picture
yeah it's been picture the pose I want
to say oh is this her singing behind the
song let's hear a little bit of it
it's gonna judge the final song off my
EP is a representation of acceptance and
it's called missing pieces
I seen pieces at the ending of a
relationship as a bit of a puzzle there
were a lot of answers that I was never
gonna get and I realized that I was
never really gonna finish this puzzle
that I was always trying to complete in
my mind it was 21 by the way oh wow yeah
no she's so y'all she 22 notes it's so
insulting Lee Young and and and that
talented never misses a beat on the job
so tell great actress the whole thing I
remember Brian on his Instagram or
something played she was playing a song
right well we did go to youtube we did
that dance to go to YouTube
member that dance we did together add
about that douche that do [ __ ] that do
she was she was if she's on YouTube for
sure yeah I want to talk about Kobe yeah
we will go real quick well this is just
her chat and performance shows yep she's
good
it could be you on the guitar chamber
you [ __ ] I'm done very very good
yeah monster dude do you remember when
we met her boyfriend sure do that guy
turned out to be a bad guy I don't know
if she wants to come you did call it oh
you know he had that arm that was
injured in the war and he couldn't use
it guess what it works
that was a [ __ ] that was phony his
arm was not paralyzed from the war he
was a soldier he's like guilty of
trouble yeah he had his arm it didn't
work and it was all sexy and stuff well
it works no he's a liar Oh God look at
me don't just sit yeah you don't look
old at all there be wow
yeah beard play it
she's such an artist good thing we can
hear you guys there's not a lot of
people talking yeah it's good good
camera work oh is that the Frog let's
not let's not that's not all right get
her in trouble of anything else in
trouble oh man but the guys like Tropic
Thunder but I got a weird wait we should
probably edit his face out with that
ready just just take his face just take
that video gets sucked anyway all right
just to the video yeah I did I think you
called it cuz you know what when we said
bye I was like we got the guy and you go
you got like this you go mm-hmm yeah
something's going on
right I was like what he goes I don't
know I was like I am you know here five
yeah it turns out he was I meet too many
people man of excellent skill I can
usually get people's intentions right
yeah you can see stuff where you're like
whoa
some people are bad what you guys do
this weekend
cat were you in Vegas again yo is there
not her Charlie Vegas not for her mm-hmm
I went for my family we actually wanted
to [ __ ] around and take my drama and her
best friend to go see Chippendales
pretend like it was a magic show but
they couldn't walk very far they were
out of breath it was real hot so we and
your grandma walk well you have to walk
like from where the the taxi drop off is
to wherever there's Chippendales at
though is it in is it in like MGM so
something like jaws you get some [ __ ] in
grandma's face do they they hump your
face but you know that yeah and by the
way okay women who go there and they go
oh whatever and then they go and they go
those are the best-looking guys I've
ever seen in my [ __ ] life but here's
the thing I have a friend who used to
date one and she's like oh they're best
thing you met all very gay she was at
this point in part was though a very gay
yeah okay but a lot of them are not they
do a lot of [ __ ] apparently they do a
lot of really you give me this whoa what
yeah the straight guys do that
all right hands hey do his thing good
body good do you think dude look at the
tires are like rubbing they're digging
the girl's face like I love your blush
like what but but they they are built
like I'm [ __ ] you know yeah they're
on all the anavar and I said it's not
steroids don't say that mother down
under so your grandma didn't get any
talk in her face
nope we're excited to get her in there
though they don't have shows like that
in Vietnam you know she's from Vietnam
mm-hmm spent most of her life here has
not learned a word of English since oh
you're trying to give grandma a heart
attack
we're trying to show her a good time
we're trying to show her the American
dream but that more like American
nightmare unless you're a gay man did
she uh but did she have fun in Vegas she
had fun she was just tired of walking
everywhere we stayed how old is she
she's like in her late 80s and it's a
hundred and seventy-three exactly Kat
what are you doing my mom thought it was
a good idea I was just trying to get
some dhikr in her face honestly yeah
I'll bring her hair there you go me and
Brian humped your face sir dude do a
dance
I'm not humping an eighty-year-old space
respect dee dee dee ten where'd you guys
steak at Caesar's Palace which wasn't a
great idea it's the olders all [ __ ]
big because I was babysitting my grandma
and her best friend and I was telling
them that I was gonna show him a good
time we're gonna go back to the room
show her porn in a racial porn she saw
thee she would always talk about the
only porn she's ever seen was a Kim
Kardashian Ray J one and she was just so
surprised when she saw a black dick Wow
she was like I've never seen something
that looks like that she was into it
yeah that's why I wanted to take her to
Chippendales did your sister tell her
about it no it was I think my mom and my
aunts way back in the day they were like
hey they want some black peepee they
just never they knew there was that
stereotype of black guys having big
dicks and they never had a chance to see
you block dick before so when the porn
got out and it was super popular they
all huddled together over a computer and
Reggie's a lot right well they didn't
know that yeah it's all right I'm not
I'm not by the way I can play my dick
chocolate
not safe at all intimidated I'll stand I
mean you know yeah I mean giant slug
when you go to black.com halt dude I
would never do so she's gonna about
those catback exhaust and they're built
like those chipping gel dancer and they
got Dixit we were like what the [ __ ] is
going on first of all congratulations
second of all I got to get to know you a
little bit know you when you talk about
black there are some Piper's I mean I
don't know how the piping fits
it's insane sometimes I'll watch I go
how's that girl in is this like a mr.
hands situation so it's the craziest
[ __ ] in the world where and it's also
but like it takes forever to get going
because it takes so much blood to get
that thing for raging it takes well I'm
like dude let's bust this nut now it
takes them forever to get reared up well
I've gotta warm up the engine gotta warm
up the engine if you go on black
hydraulics you deal with a lot of
hydraulics
I have it on good authority that you've
got to get that's Kim Kardashian with a
dick Mary black dick only prefers the
black okay well um yeah but I haven't
good authority you got to squeeze their
buttocks Shan Shan it's a pump your fear
and your family's pretty open with
sexual stuff then huh okay yes my family
they're out here Wilin out honestly what
do you mean Wilin out they're very very
crude people they're very crass
interesting Caribbean cultures aren't
like that they're not my family really
mm-hmm
did your sister talk about her
relationships with dudes and stuff to
your family uh no they all know that she
prefers to date black guys but she's not
she's pretty private with her dating is
she iteration yeah they we shot some of
those scenes
yeah the mom-and-pop set it up right
good values not they're worth like a
billion dollars yeah no no I know
[ __ ] I was a good it was a calculation
yeah weird weird thing and I still a
Michael that's all right I know chin
what do you do your own daughter
cool
uh-huh well I put together a TV stand
floor stand okay that took an hour what
else can't remember much more just
pretty much that's it hung out at home a
little bit of Jeffrey Dahmer vibe going
on with the glasses you're seeing down
below you've got a little corner of your
mouth there but um so you just do you
what you do at night at night you had
the most general here the thing is I
don't remember it it must have missed
super boring I mean we know just chill
watched I have no idea what he does that
night yeah um that worked on videos you
just do stuff in general and walk around
yeah I was some guys and girls and
California right yeah season finale
laughs did you watch it
yep it was I mean I thought was good not
great I expected more from the finale /
last two have been a lot like it looks
great but I like finale yeah it was cool
I saw Hobbes and Shaw did you took my
son and he took my friend took his son
and we were in Utah and I went to see
Hobbes inshaaallah I gotta tell you it
is the most over-the-top it's the most
over-the-top movie of all sake you will
love it but it was [ __ ] fun and evil
lion cartoon yes not for me people one
point the rock is holding a chain and a
helicopter
yes it's Santa and he's holding that it
was very interesting he's he's doing all
the steroids he's doing all of them and
why not
well III I just can't like Derek and
Essam love these movies because they're
like oh I can't wait to kill them but
I'm like dude you can pay me to see
Hobson yeah I just have no internet it's
just so crazy it's so crazy over-the-top
it's so nuts they've got such a huge
rating on Rotten Tomatoes like 90 oh yes
it's a blast
people love it guys are these guys are
killing and the Samoans you know all I
want to look like it's a Simone good
like if you see there's a scene in the
island where he goes back home and all
his Samoa all their dance there oh yeah
they're all giant men like you and some
of them are
when she lifts and diet properly there
they're the coolest looking
[ __ ] on the plan I mean how bad
did it was the rocks and rocks like I'll
do the movie but we got to do the
Hawaiian look at him he's actually not
CGI that's what he looks like right a
little bit but yes a little bit um you
don't be interesting if the guy who
provides him all his steroids wrote a
book like a tell-all like this what
though the cycle Rock's been doing for
the last 30 mm nowadays we know that's
what he's but no it'd be cool to find
out exactly what he's on for the
gearheads yeah I think it'd be so cool I
think I like his diet and everything but
yeah wouldn't it be probably just like
deca Anna ball and all that stuff you
would know no I bet he's not likes arms
like HGH and like he's on a certain kind
cuz he can't be bloated and then you
know he swole year round so then he
can't be doing just deck all the time
well your core area say it's two so I'm
sure he's running blood non-stop like a
goddamn Jiffy Lube so it's like it'd be
soap to me be so fascinating to get his
exact plan of what he's doing
did you see he ever seen his dad yeah
Rock job Josh also on steroids though of
course yeah but again that he's the rock
is gifted super gifted just genetically
and then when you put look at him
synthetic testosterone on top of that
you have a creature of [ __ ] excellent
yes his dad is he close to his that was
dad passed away but yeah okay he was
though all right what spell I think yeah
well she dropped resto was okay desde uh
he grew up like you know in wrestling
around his dad yeah look at that mom was
someone dad was african-american
but wouldn't be interesting to find out
like like Jerrod Butler when he did
three hundred like dude what was your
cycle man they can only do CrossFit
give me a break what exactly were you
doing yes or any of these guys more uh
[ __ ] Mark Wahlberg when he did you
know that that movie with the rock dude
what did you take what was your diet
like it I think if you could get to the
underbelly of Hollywood and peds or like
Will Smith in alley dude you put on
thirty pounds of lean mouth what you do
do yeah it's a it's a be so fascinating
yes yeah we're never gonna find out but
it'd be fasting
pain and gain one of my favorite movies
race not the true story really look at
Mark Wahlberg there he's huge
is it a good whether they play body
pillars I choose story about basically
two personal trainers and they start to
sell steroids and then they take a guy
hostage to get money and it's just
backfires and it's great jeez it's crazy
really good movie though I'll never
forget I was at bars wall work though
yeah I was at Gold's Gym a long time ago
and a woman came out she was a body but
kind of muscular and and this cop came
out and goes you know Tatum Tatum
Johnson she goes yeah and he goes just
takes his wallet out with a badge and he
goes cuz I've been looking for you for a
while and she goes she just dropped her
bag she goes oh no he goes take it easy
relax she's gonna take you in and cuff
her right there right in the parking lot
what was she doing I probably say my
Salinas selling steroids or some kind of
a drug you know what's weird is I feel
like if you're the government do you
really give a [ __ ] you like one guy
selling steroids out of the gym I don't
know like you have such a bigger fish
whatever it was something was cash buy
degree he came up to her Tom do you like
did a guy about your size tall and she
knew not said no well she knew he was
sick yeah clearly and experienced a lot
of [ __ ] he was like I saw this video
of a cop who the guy shot at him the guy
you see the guy come up and shoot at him
he's a kid it gets out of the van and
shoots at him and the guy keeps with the
cookies they cover you could see he's
just a grizzled veteran cop probably a
soldier or something and he's just so
calm and he looks under the [ __ ] car
under the van and the guy's hiding and
he just shoots him in the foot just goes
bang like that [ __ ]
because but he just kind of casually
walks over kicks the gun away
cuff some Jesus yeah that kind of a
guy's just the guy's just been around it
doesn't get flustered you just went just
casually I'm gonna get that tattoo on my
shirt on my shoulder do you should do it
uh dude that could be on me if we got
some dekha yeah I'll do it if you do it
that's all i'ma say I'll literally
that's exactly how we would look dude we
should do you and I for real
I should see how shredded and [ __ ]
big I can get in-house credit
for me is how big can I get for you is
how shredder can you that'd be fun would
you do it yeah I would do it if we had
someone I have I I can find I can find a
ball yeah the great doctor for us
I'd be down all right now don't pee
before you can I get a p2 and we'll talk
about I want to talk about Kobe yeah
look everybody sometimes needs someone
to talk to I know I've been there I know
you've been there yeah but I need
someone who knows what they're doing
you can't just be talking to my friends
give me bad as you can spend a fortune
going to a therapist which I've done you
talk to a trained professional a license
all that anything's wrong with that
nothing wrong with sometimes you don't
have the funds you don't have time right
so guess why others better help better
help it's not a crisis line so I
self-help it's a professional
counselling done securely online start
talking somebody in under 24 hours okay
your service available for clients
worldwide you can log on anytime send a
message to your counselor you get a
timely thoughtful response these are
real people they some rope you can do it
through video or through phone like yes
dude it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is even available so visit
better help calm slash fighter and join
over 500,000 peace a half a million
people are doing it already its class
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional fighter and the kid
listeners you guys get 10% off your
first month better help calm slash finer
that's better help calm slash fighter
talk to somebody get your mind right uh
look guys you're looking at me right now
if you're watching this and you see you
see the glow you see how young I look I
don't age dude I get back to the setting
they're like Brian let them how the [ __ ]
do you look so young
well I don't know it's called on it dude
I got all my nutritional optimizing
potions I need yeah and use real
emotions how do you think Brian
remembers the script he's on alpha brain
mass inject it right that's my why is my
breath smell so damn good got health
because your guts right man's right and
they just sent me my battle ropes cuz
you know me I'm the keto kid now I'm
down some weight but I need on its help
they got everything ropes a keto kid yep
I got
balla ropes get shred city population me
and you guys we got joint oil glutamine
creatine electrolytes the total Kido
baby baby assaulted Waterman watermelon
I use melatonin spray how about there
are so nutrients whatever you need man
Kido kids let's take it by the horns a
credit you ever done the shrimp tech
hell yeah I've done the SH I swear to
God I swear to God the shrewdest Tech
III take that [ __ ] and I'm like why
after my work and I'm like why am I
still have I have crazy energy that [ __ ]
is the best thing I've ever taken that
stuff makes me crazy shroom tech mmm I
take you out for brain I feel like I ran
out of my shrimp to feel like Elon Musk
go to on it calm slash fighter and get
temps off the entire dam site from
supplements to workout gear everything
jump on board right now it's on it calm
slash fighter you're welcome whoop all I
gotta say is whoop if you want it you
want to track your sleep if you want to
track your heart rate wealth in general
whoop there it is yeah what are you
talking about bro that that black band
does everything for you listen sometimes
I get on a workout machine or sometimes
I run I'm like mmm it says up on this
million calories wrong dude now I know
exactly how many I burn cuz I'm looped
up baby
in this new 3.0 strap just a little
strap that cupcakes my heart rate
non-stop mad cuz I said a hundred times
per second 24/7 which is very very
precise and do you have the 3.0 there
yeah dude this is the new one alright
has a five-day battery life I haven't
charged this thing it forever actually
health analytics dude resting heart
rates sleep quality
heart rate variability you get recovery
squirrel when you wake up which lets
know how hard their body is working
which provides insight into your body
and it's ready to be pushed and they
lutely wanna do the best way you can
track recovery the how much you strain
during your workout keep scrolling down
please chin your recovery your strain
everything man your sleep your sleep
everything and woo provides insights
through the app from the heart rate data
collected to help users make better
training habits and prefer perform
optimally on daily basis so if you're
like man
I know Friday is Mikey day I'm gonna
perform on Friday it will show you how
to get there with your sleep if you may
be getting bad sleep and interrupt sleep
without realizing it and that's why
whoop is something that's it's a cheap
way to actually learn how well your
sleep and kido kids get on it man
because I was kind of just maintaining
my weight or even gain awake because I
thought I was losing this much weight
because I was burning this many calories
not true but now I know precisely how
much I'm losing what I need to do get it
right now join it subscription plan once
a month you pay a subscription fee and
you give it the exact down to the nitty
gritty detailed of what you're losing
and right now the [ __ ] listeners you
guys can get $30 off your woot
membership when you check out whoop calm
that's WH o o P calm use the code
fighter at check out and gets $30 off
optimize the way you train no more
guessing none of that get whoop whoop
there it is was the Kobe Covington thing
surprising to you
no really why have you watched on the
floor yeah it never gets tired but I
just thought fighting somebody like
Robbie Lawler who I thought looked
amazing amazing and visually looked
amazing yeah yeah the coat was just it's
just a bad matchup for Robbie come out
of the same camp too used to they're a
different camp oh they are now yeah okay
I was just so good man so good inverse
come on when's the move they don't like
each other
great matchup two similar styles both
both wrestlers both you know both cardio
machines yeah that's the fight what do
you think oh I do I pray give kymaro the
slight advantage even though he said he
had surgery had that hernia thing he had
something else going on so if he's ready
to go though think he's right level a
low well no let's say Colby's actually a
more decorated wrestler oh yeah
he's all-american pack pac-12 what
Oregon State like cope with you Marcus
Christ he also does cardio with [ __ ]
camera at Cameron Haynes though good God
yeah good God what about who's better
striker tomorrow is more power but Colby
strikings pretty [ __ ] get there but
Kamara has more power neither ones like
knockout artist though yeah you see who
gets taken down though ah that's gonna
be alright what he got chin all right
first one this crazy story so there is a
seven-year-old in India who has always
experienced some sort of pain in his
mouth or two but they took him to a
doctor recently and they found half a
pound of mass they called it a bag of
mass within his mouth they operated on
it and found five hundred and twenty six
pieces of teeth why just it's just an
abnormality yeah freak that Sharkboy
right and took it well calm Sharkboy
yeah dude shirks in India no I'm
swarming with sharks but but also be the
gone Shark Boy because like sharks cos
they put out teeth all the time they're
like rows I guess but did he look
deformed
no I yeah he didn't have the greatest
set of teeth but you couldn't tell that
there were 526 it came in like a sack it
was all together they have to break it I
know like like they don't specify where
Ryan is behind his mom and little little
chips and I took one out what they told
ya although his video shows boy after
this little boy all having a lot better
after a recent dental procedure
it wasn't your typical flossing and
cleaning though that's because he had
over 500 teeth removed from his mouth oh
he didn't look that in a funny hat when
you have kids you just love everything
out did you know I mean like you can't
bear it cute little boy oh they're shown
where they were at that's insane man let
a little nub now are they not there they
never get that for sure don't pull them
to shape like that dude but dude are
they coming back is it just going for
good now nope it's gone for good
yeah that poor dude that was the [ __ ]
hurt yeah hey alright what else you got
Oh God for modern medicine that's all I
have to say for reals so do you guys
remember a story a while back about this
little boy taking his grandpa's car to
go to a liquor store nearby to get
snacks yeah made it alright
right like he [ __ ] up some stuff but
yeah like a mailbox yeah but he made it
not bad
yeah so a little ten-year-old girl tried
to do the same thing with her mom's car
to go to McDonald's the only thing is
that she ended up getting lost and she
tried to make a turn in a car hit her
luckily nobody was hurt she got like a
couple of bruises but she's okay so
apparently there's just an influx of
kids stealing cars now I wonder why just
to go get snacks I mean just ask the
parent to get some goddamn snacks and
she was in a tahoe - yeah that's how big
a good car but this cardigan yakun true
but the little girl is okay she never
made it to McDonald's though I mean I
couldn't go nowhere without me knowing
sometimes you don't pretend though you
never know never know dude I think your
kid's gonna be real big at ten so I
think he is you okay since no drug he's
gonna come in and start bullying me at
ten
I'll boo you right hands are already my
size what else you got
darn good [ __ ] he's already got traps
for real think he's on an alibi so a
video of a fan of a baseball fan went
viral hitched a ninety six miles per
hour ball a couple times and he actually
got signed two weeks later from the
Oakland A's this happened in Colorado
his brother goes guys we were just
chilling at the Rockies baseball game my
brother decided to step into a speed
[ __ ] challenge
he hit 96 miles per hour at MLB let's
get him signed and they signed it
claimed he'd been practicing apparently
he's yeah he played baseball Jesus
they say that's so rare holy and see oh
dude and the A's are like we'll take him
yep
they must know he can piss 96 and that's
a random number to yell out yep can he
do a hundo nerdy doesn't end up getting
200 in this video he does he doesn't not
back to back speeds like this throw in 9
so the A's are gonna put him in like
single a or some [ __ ] the start what a
great story
it's crazy cuz the year before last
August he actually joined a league to
try to play baseball again just
recreationally he end up getting in a
car accident got hit in December he this
video went viral and he was actually
trying to talk to somebody from the
Oakland A's about like potentially
trying out and when they got ahold of
this video they signed him two weeks
later [ __ ] man
what kind of deal they signed him to
easing them man
yeah for sure Myers that but how long
has he been playing baseball since high
school yeah he stopped after he
graduated legit baseball player yeah he
was like a rock this thing I think he
was he's trying to get signed he is
trying only [ __ ] that's cool what a
great story that's amazing that's so
cool I hope he does well yeah he played
growing up but then after he graduated
he stopped he had a couple games I he
would play with those friends and notice
that he could still throw really well so
he started so practiced just Genovese
that's crazy man what else you got
that's it for those right let's do this
one no the grass Tyson is getting
roasted I'm away we shouldn't be talking
about this right John deaf tweet about
the reason Matt here's my thing it's
just not the time Neil probably not he
was I think what he was trying to say is
that it's to me trying to devalue what
parents know I think what he's maybe
trying to say is that if you look at
like I was actually surprising to me so
48 past 48 hours 34 people to mass
shootings terrible but 500 people died
of medical errors 300 tooth flew 200
vision suicide 200 car accidents 42
homicide by a handgun it's a lot he said
often emotion just one more respectable
than to data which is which is true but
you're right timing was was timing a
little incense no
doing though yeah I gotta be honest it
makes me laugh less of a fan of him I
gotta be honest I saw my goddamn dude
well baby maybe do that in Julie yeah I
think he was trying to be I think what
he's trying to do is be helpful and put
things into perspective but he was
Tony's too old for that just tone-deaf
too old sometimes you get tone-deaf
that's all that's not the time yeah
that's the time
yeah yeah that's a bummer right like
yeah I like the guy can't defend him on
that one I went out I saw it I do think
I do think it's interesting though I
kind of went I do think in some ways it
could help some people put it into
perspective you know you know I'm a 502
medical errors 302 the flu that's a lot
I do think that these this is different
though because this is somebody
deliberately trying to kill kill people
with a high it's a real problem like it
yeah and but and it's only happening in
the United Steel political so so you're
gonna see some real political winds
change in terms of most Americans are
like look democratic or repetitive get
it yeah go what but but but how about
universal background checks or whatever
and I think that the you can't be you
cannot be a Republican or the NRA and
just say and do nothing go just be human
man you can't just well you the answer
can't be nothing you know what else to
answer Kippy
oh it's a mental illness there's
mentalists around the world and you have
yet well when somebody has has body
armor any and an ak-47 oh and then
killed his sister so I mean how about
that family a lot losing to kids like
that so you know it's well it's done I
don't know move on yeah keep talking
about these jobs but Neil deGrasse Tyson
that so I know everyone loves him but I
have seen him in the past do stuff to
get attention I would feel like he was
doing stuff to get attention I don't
know why but it seems like sometimes a
little bit of a thought move like it's a
little bit of like cloud chasing well
yes I tweaked 2008 time during the year
but right when that's when something
like he knows he knows what he's doing
he knows he's also a scientist so
scientists do this like scientists can
they don't be he's okay he's also not
yeah he's not the same kind of scientist
he's a scientist that wants to be
in marble the guys part of his job is to
put things into perspective what she
always does he's always done it I just
think this is a misstep I don't I just
felt this way about him would I I do
think he's a little bit of a Fame [ __ ]
I do phone cuz he keeps doing this I'm
like oh dude I listen I know you want to
keep he did something when there's
movies coming out he said all the things
are wrong in the movie but no even just
him being on all these different
television shows and podcasts in
everything I don't know I just sensed it
from a while ago I just when I saw this
I was like he's also really interesting
100%
he must be famous yeah and this is give
this five designer this kid Stockwell
it's no different than you know all
right
he's a proc II he's been released from
Sweden he was there for what almost a
month now
that's ridiculous [ __ ] I do that those
guys should have been [ __ ] stomped
when non-recognition I [ __ ] those guys
those are terrible guys hey those pieces
of [ __ ] they weren't even Swedish and
how about our governments wait after
Sweden as they came in let him go
there's me some [ __ ] that's what
happened so the US government this had
negative consequences to the u.s. world
these guys I mean we saw the video and
it was terrible man
yeah those pieces there do it because
he's a famous black man like they were
they were like they were Arabic of some
kind they were they were immigrants
themselves and I feel Sweden they were
they were something wrong with those
guys those guys were very bad dudes that
one dude had a giant neck tattoo as well
which I mean this is the neck tattoo but
still I mean like it was interested if
that dude if I got more famous that
guilt yeah it's not good man well yeah
he's he's also someone that said he's
never went back Snoop Dogg said he was
never going to go back before serve the
sweden's a very liberal country Sweden
is not Sweden this very if you want to
be an N in GL it's a Swedish jail it's
just that those guys why all of us know
that those guys I've never seen anybody
who needed to be punched harder than
those [ __ ] dudes everyone got
aggravated watching those guys I mean
they what happened to those pieces of
[ __ ] nothing nothing
the guy they'd even didn't even get
already molested or anything nothing you
guys are bad dudes man I'll buy a sup
rock your fan yep all right yeah let me
just I don't want to tell you the story
first but look at this oh you already
saw this I haven't seen the
don't tell her what's going on you will
tell me gentle first of all you think
she's let me tell him let me tell so
look at that picture show show the
picture just show the video please for
it to show the video and let me tell you
what this is looks we're done that's a
doll doll yeah I Brennan I'm not a doll
that's a dude yeah hold on I tell you
what this is laughs all boo do donut
shirt so right there very tell war bra
caseous infinity's this is a this is a
Brazilian gang leader who was in jail
his 19 year old daughter came to visit
him and he dressed up like her she
stayed in the jail and he [ __ ]
escaped almost made it out as his
daughter with that mask bullying that
outfit look how did he get caught he got
he was being he was acting nervous yeah
and they were like something's wrong and
they caught holy well how genius is that
so let's artists so in the jail
oh the DA is going to prison not - way
to go dude yeah or she could just say
[Applause]
and by the way how many people were
decapitated then oh my god did you see
that me then playing soccer with the
head no me neither
oh ha ha ha my video out there yeah they
they go how ruthless are these [ __ ]
cartels in Brazil and the 15 guys were
could decapitate if da I didn't see any
of those 15 but 58 people died in the
prison riots right um two gangs fighting
and then they would decapitate the heads
another game and there's video of them
on the roof playing soccer with the guy
said yeah it's just a different human
being there you go shout out to Brazil
don't be in a girl but never cook with
Wow
you don't want to be in a Brazilian jail
it's not a good idea South African jails
Brazilian jails not a good idea
rush and jails not funny they're not
funny not funny no wow that's
fascinating yeah it looks weird right
anyone else ruin for him to get out uh
yeah a little bit a little bit a genius
know if you get out - genius I didn't
catch him later terrible person I'm sure
alright yeah would you wear something
like I mean it's obviously is something
going on there do you like sunglasses
really I'm doing anything to get out
that's amazing right there no that's
fantastic
what else you got Kevin Spacey showed up
in Rome to do a a random poetry thing
out in public crowd gathered makeup guys
look like nut to the Kevin Spacey's Mac
dude but Louie CK they said did some
shows that day knees and just [ __ ]
crushed crushed yeah I mean I guess he
opened up and went you know zany's is
you know seats like 260 look parent last
time I was in national I was doing some
giant because I was at the Opera you
know national opera it's cool though so
funny it's so funny look man how long
how door see how long do you want to how
long do you want these guys to do you
want him just go away forever
well they see his stuff got drop yeah
cuz that kid that kid dropped it you
know he was messing around with them
through the text like this guy's
actually grabbed my dick that guy yeah
but I'll stop mom's girlfriend she suck
is did good whatever
what else you got gonna say this let me
see what he's doing all the charge I
just play a little bit of this that one
in particular for sure what a great
actor my face he's doing poetry about a
boxer who's wounded but fights back
here's my chess save it I didn't
memorize the words give way before me
every time there is something that
doesn't add up the voices lost I don't
know why never know well we have a will
he come back yes
you think so mm-hmm you know these
things you're good with thank you comes
back yeah I mean who doesn't well
there's got to be a TV show where
they're gonna want to get bigger I don't
want to stop that's the worst thing
we've heard about like that is that the
kid that was the big one that was 130
years ago the actor remember the the
younger actor boy that he said he went
to his thirty years ago 35 years ago 35
years ago he said he picked him up put
him on a bed he's 14 they had been oh oh
do is drunk and high not just whatever
was Kevin Spacey
but there was a 60 I forget what they
call it II 60 last night about this
track coach at UCLA I've heard about
this so he's been a track he's a Olympic
gold medalist but he denies it he's been
a track coach for like 40-something
years black guy and he teaches at UCLA
well he was molesting kids for like 40
years like non-stop and then yeah so
check this out this guy who's a young
track guy on UCLA started work with him
he molested him was like brothers dick
and stuff we stretching them and it was
like everyone knew he was doing this but
he all he'd there it is 44 44 years 41
allegations now they're catch him but
check this out
so homeboy this guy who got molested
wrote a blog about how he's going to the
UK some random guy goes hey Mel that
coach we used to work with UCLA just in
the comments goes I got some [ __ ] to
tell you for what a reason all like a
bunch of people who follow him also ran
track with his coach in the Comets go
he's to touch many schedules 60,000
comments later they go oh [ __ ] there's a
shitload of people that he molested that
guy who made the video this is him goes
UCLA and goes hey man remember when you
[ __ ] with me and molested me and my
dick and all this stuff is you're going
to goddamn you're gonna prison man and
now they don't they they eventually
opened up a case because if it's after
three years they can't do anything right
but there's been so many victims they
found some victim they molested
literally the day that video was shot
he's [ __ ] now they copy it looks like
he's not able
Walker something he has a walker but
he's been running track since he's like
three he's that like he's a Olympic
medal gold medalist it's interesting
though it's finally caught up with him
also though when when I was in college
and if you started touching my dick
you're gonna have a problem you
understand me yeah this but this guy
would go after young boys who like [ __ ]
they go after young boys and then he was
like that he was like the guy who would
get everyone to the Olympics so they
would take it I don't want to be Olympic
that bad you touched my daily hours I
mean I would squeal do a young man like
you I'm a young man get the [ __ ] off my
dick will you do here's what he did
though he did it to straight males so
they were so embarrassed
oh they tell anyone no none of them are
gay I would have been like I would have
been like hey bro I'm gonna punch in
what the [ __ ] you doing
it hurts my dick when I'm 19 see what
happens it's tough though if you want to
go to the Olympics and he's your way to
the Olympics I guess you'd be like this
is so weird you won that gold medal bro
I guess yeah he's super creepy wearer
what else you got you why not one more
yeah one more we get Brian out all right
so this is just a happy one I saw this
on Kamiya Cabela's Instagram and it's
just a daughter and father seeing in one
of her songs the one she does he's so
cute look at ours she smiles
turn it up
oh my god Singh she can hit the dog huh
now she's beatboxing he can sink thank
you that's why she could see him cuz
he's really hate dad take you down the
next up more about the kids room you
know dad he's super yeah that's pretty
much him sing in the rest yeah
she's so cute look at the way she's
moving back yeah I know she's smile dad
was like this is my time to shine that's
why this
hey guys honey bought some Madonna
before I forget thank you forever I did
a fund me for my friend D'Angelo
Mitchell his mother Annie gentles was
murdered in front of him he tried to
stop the three [ __ ] who did it yeah
he got shot himself but we raised almost
$12,000 anything more you can do I'd
appreciate it we're gonna leave it up
for a little bit longer he could really
use the money obviously he's shot
through the kidneys he can't work for a
long while and he doesn't have money and
he's got a ten-year-old son and I'm
really appreciating the go fund me on
your page yep thank you you're gonna go
find me on my page on the Instagram as a
kid of retweet it so you guys can find
it will retweet it tomorrow morning so
that'd be great day morning if I don't
these day morning I appreciate that
so thanks everybody for your generosity
it really really makes a difference
thank you
I'm in Portland next week dude Portland
helium Thursday Friday Saturday which
spell Lacey and Derek posted and come
along with me love it voodoo doughnuts
baby I can't touch him but I'll watch
you guys eat in Portland Helia have one
nope that's I can't nope
next Thursday Friday Saturday I'm in
Portland after that we're in Auroville
bryan callen you and me that is August
31st
all right country casino me and Bryan do
some stay up together then after that
September 20 through 21st so I'm in
Houston Denver after that t5k dot-com
for tickets we just released our area 51
tea fat K shirts get them on this
website right now
they're almost sold out Brian Brian abhi
at the coal country casino in Oroville
and I am now going back to the set of
schooled I'm late and it's worth it get
you some dude all right guys this final
kid we're out